المنطقه الحدوديه ضواحي بيل جرود اليوم
كما تحدث رئيس المنطقه بانها وبسبب خطوره
الوضع هناك وتعرضها للقصف طوال ليله يوم
امس الذي ادى طبعا الى مقتل شخصين تحدث عن
ضروره اجلاء جميع المواطنين الذين هم على
الحدود وهي طبعا هذه المنطقه الشباكنا
بالتحديد هي منطقه تبعد نحو 5 كم عن
الحدود ونحوه 90 كيلومتر عن خاركه في
الاوركان الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هي تشهد منذ
شهر مايو الماضي
قصفا شديدا واستواء كان باستهداف عن طريق
الصواريخ او سواء كان ذلك باستخدام
المسيرات وبالتالي تم اجراء نحو 4000
مواطن روسي الى مراكز اقامه مؤقته في
مدينه الروسيه في ثلاث مناطق مراكز تم
توزيع هؤلاء المواطنين
المسؤولون هناك يتحدثون عن ان الوضع لا
حتى الان لا يتحمل عوده المواطنين ويدعون
الى مغادره جميع الجميع منازلهم لحين يتم
طبعا السيطره على الوضع في هذه المنطقه
احمد طبعا جميع المناطق الروسيه الحدوديه
التي هي قريبه من الحدود الاوكرانيه هي في
تتعرض بشكل مستمر ويومي لي قصف اما سواء
كان عن طريق استخدام المسيرات كما تحدثت
ايضا السلطات في منطقه كورسك وفي منطقه
كان هناك
استهدافي هذه المناطق سواء كان باستخدام
المسيرات والصواريخ ايضا لذلك كما تحدثت
مسبقا هناك الان الوضع في منطقه بالتحديد
يزداد سوءا بسبب القصف المستمر لهذه
المنطقه من الجانب الاوكراني ما ادى الى
طبعا دعوات في اجراء جميع هذه المناطق من
السكان
احمد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات